c'est dans la tranquillité d'une forêt
de pain en périphérie d'isium que les
tombes et les fosses communes ont été
découvertes des centaines de croix
certaines portant des indications des
noms des dates parcelles les environs
[Musique]
des militaires spécialisés en médecine
légale ont été dépêchés sur place avec
la tâche d'exhumer les cadavres qui sont
enterrés certains depuis aussi longtemps
que mars dernier
les analyses d’adn et des autopsies
seront effectuées sur les dépouilles
afin de savoir qui a été tué et comment
selon les autorités ukrainiennes il y
aurait la plus de 400 corps
c'est un véritable charnier rempli de
personnes assassinées dit le président
ukrainien des enfants des adultes des
civils des militaires certains torturés
même
volodimeki évoque des crimes de guerre
et appelle la communauté internationale
a réagir
cela s'apparente à des crimes de guerre
admet le chef de la diplomatie
américaine ceux qui ont commis et
ordonné ces crimes doivent être punis un
message portez aussi par la ministre
canadienne des Affaires étrangères et
par l'Union européenne
les exhumations devraient se poursuivre
encore plusieurs jours à isium libéré de
l'occupation russe cette semaine les
habitants de la ville auront besoin de
temps pour se libérer aussi de leur
cauchemars ici lise Villeneuve
Radio-Canada Montréal